if you're looking to start out in
architectural photography or
architectural videography you probably
don't need as much as you think
i used to have my own business running
photography and geography for
architectural show homes
before i became a qualified architect so
this video is
full of some inside advice that i'm
hoping will be able to inspire some of
you
[Music]
what's going on guys my name is david
thomage and welcome back to the channel
like i mentioned i'm a practicing
architect in the state of western
australia
and today we are talking about
architectural photography and
videography
i used to run my own business doing
photography and videography
i used to have every single thing under
the sun all the big dslr cameras
the heavy gimbals the lighting kits the
works
it costs an absolute fortune and nobody
can afford that starting out so i
thought i'd make this video today from
an architect's perspective
of what you actually need to start out
and produce good quality work
now don't get me wrong the big dslr
cameras and the gimbals are still
required
when you reach a certain point in your
career but when you're just starting out
and trying to build up your portfolio
trying to build up your resume
you definitely don't need all of this
the first thing i recommend everybody
starting out in the industry to do
is go and do their research learn what
people really like
learn what kind of videos are trending
learn what kind of photos doing well
how they color graded where are they
taking from what angle lenses are
they're using
and then the same thing for videography
how are they positioning themselves what
angles they're getting
how do they actually move around in that
video
so recently i've sold all of my
photography and videography gear and
moved away from that industry i focused
on my architectural career
but i still have to do a lot of social
media presentation
obviously i'm still on youtube so what i
now do
is only run around with a smartphone
i've purchased the best smartphone on
the market which was the samsung
s20 ultra at the time now it's probably
the s21 ultra
if you're in the same boat i would
recommend getting a good smartphone to
be able to do the following steps
a good smartphone would either be the
top of the range samsung
s21 ultra or the brand new iphone 12 pro
max
both of these devices are relatively
expensive and probably do cost
just as much as a dslr camera however
most of you guys probably already have
these devices in your pocket
so it is able to be able to transition
into this industry a lot easier so
if you have just the phone it's actually
very possible to do
architectural photography and
videography especially just handheld
you just have to know what you're doing
so if you're doing architecture
photography
handheld is very easy you just go around
clicking videography is a different
beast
with videography you have to be able to
understand how you're moving
so if you're doing architectural
videography on a smartphone just
handheld
make sure you're always holding it with
two hands and taking very slow
movements you don't want to step too far
you don't want to go too far
you only want to be able to limit
yourself in how far you can reach
so if you have to take 10 steps don't do
it
reach forward move take the next step
redo that shot because there is no way
you're going to get steady shots
with a handheld device no matter how
good it is at the present moment in 2021
secondly if you're doing handheld shots
it's important to remember your frame
rates
now i've stuffed this up multiple times
and i still do it to date
so keep it in the back your mind as much
as you can you want to be filming at 60
frames per second
at 4k if your phone has the ability to
go higher
to 120 frames a second at 4k
then go to that but the minimum you want
to be filming at is 60 frames a second
at 4k
because it allows you to slow that
footage down in post-production
and actually work out all the kinks and
any shakes that might come along with it
if you've managed to get a couple jobs
just starting out with your smartphone
handheld
you've made a little bit of money now
it's time to move on to the accessories
the first accessory i would recommend is
the dji om4
gimbal it is a very small compact gimbal
that has a very versatile amount of
moves
it makes any shot a lot smoother and a
lot easier to create
so if for example you do need to take
those long shots where you have to walk
5
10 meters in that one shot or follow a
subject to create that shot you're
looking for
well then now you have the possibility
whereas previously as handheld you
wouldn't have had that possibility it
would just be too jumpy too shaky
and the unusable unprofessional footage
at least if you do get a gimbal as well
it also gives you the added benefit of
continuing to film
only in 30 frames a second or 24 frames
a second
this way you don't have to slow down
motion you don't have to make it seem
unnatural
it can be a very natural fluid flow or
very cinematic if you're filming at 24
frames a second so the key advice there
is
make sure you know your frames per
second and you know your movements
again similar to the previous advice
it's important to know how you're
shooting
not what you're shooting on so if you're
handheld you slow down the footage
if you're not handheld and you have
stabilizers you have that ability
to do it in the natural flow of motion
now it's all well and good to have
amazing photos
but what you're going to quickly realize
is that everybody is good at editing and
everybody knows how to edit so quickly
brush
up on your photoshop skills your
lightroom skills
and your premiere pro skills you can use
any other software of course but these
are my go-to's
with architectural photography you can
bring these images into lightroom
edit them and make them look so much
better than they actually are
anyway that's all for me today guys
thank you so much for watching i hope
you enjoyed the video
if you did make sure you smash that
subscribe button down below
this video forms one of my 28 videos in
28 days
so it would usually be i'll see you next
monday but in this case
i'll see you tomorrow